we welcome you to cbs this morning
unfortunately we begin with very sad
news again we're going back to surfside
florida
where what was left of the champlain
tower south condo building
has now been demolished last night the
crew set off a string of explosives
bringing down the high-rise and a cloud
of dust
now one big reason was to make it safer
for rescuers that are still
combing through the rubble especially
did you hear a tropical storm is
barreling toward the area
manuel bajorkas is in surfside right now
manuel
at least 24 people we know are confirmed
dead that means 121 are still missing
good morning to you what are the rescue
efforts look like right now
well gail as you mentioned the
demolition was set to clear the way for
crews to resume that search the part of
the building that remained
standing was right over here where now a
crane being used in the search
marks the spot people here in surfside
are once again waking up to a vastly
different landscape
last night nearby residents were urged
to close their windows
and their vents to avoid the dust from
the collapse
as officials acknowledged it would once
again mark a
painful chapter for survivors and
families of the victims
at 10 30 p.m a loud boom rattled through
the neighborhood
and in mere seconds the remains of the
surfside high-rise
crashed to the ground crews prepared for
the demolition in just two days
officials had stressed concerns the
structure was at risk of falling
and could be further damaged by tropical
storm elsa
they say teams will now be able to
search for victims in parts of the
rubble that were previously off limits
we will have our first responders back
on the pile to
immediately resume their work in an
emergency hearing
less than an hour before the demolition
a judge denied a homeowner's request to
re-enter the building
to search for her cat officials say they
use drones and thermal imaging to find
life
with little success but they acknowledge
tearing down the high rise represents
another loss for residents
we have families that have their lives
possessions in those units
we had families that had their life
possessions in the units that were
destroyed so
this is really just a continuation of
the tragedy
destroying the building will also affect
the investigation into what caused the
initial collapse as allen kilzheimer
the forensic engineering expert hired by
surfside
it will complicate it some because we
will have to do it from
new debris rather than from what's
standing in the air
he says the remnants of the building
will be removed so they can be examined
and tested clearing the way for more
work at the site
once the area is clear we're going to be
wanting to take
samples of the soil below and we want to
dig pits
down to look at the foundations
one survivor we've spoken with who lived
in the section that was just demolished
said they were urged
not to watch the demolition not only
because they would see the rest of their
possessions destroyed
but because it could trigger the trauma
from the night
of the disaster jerica man while truly
unbelievable thank you i know a lot of
people still holding on to hope there